the new film from writer director
charlie kaufman i'm thinking of ending
things is the kind of movie that's sure
to linger in your mind for quite a while
after the credits finish rolling in it a
young woman heads out on a snowy road
trip with her boyfriend to meet his
parents
but despite that simple premise nothing
in the movie is truly simple what
follows is a strange journey through the
heart of a blizzard a deeply
uncomfortable dinner and a spooky final
trip to a high school
along with an ending that seems to raise
more questions and answers
but what exactly that ending means might
not be super clear
especially if you're not completely
brushed up on your rogers and
hammerstein musicals
confused that's not surprising put
chains on the tires and ride along with
us
as we attempt to explain the ending of
i'm thinking of ending things
spoilers ahead it doesn't take long for
i'm thinking of ending things to make
the viewer begin to suspect that all is
not as it seems
early in the film there's ample evidence
that jake can hear what his girlfriend
is thinking
either asking her to repeat herself or
just looking at her whenever she thinks
something that she wants to keep secret
from him
i'm thinking of ending things huh what
did you say something
no i don't think so additionally the
girlfriend's name changes over the
course of the film it starts as lucy but
soon she's answering to louisa
stranger still even though she's called
these names she receives phone calls
from contacts with those very same names
on her phone
calls she pointedly ignores additionally
very early in the drive the girlfriend
pulls down the passenger seat mirror and
we see that it's broken
a clear symbol for her fractured broken
identity we also get glimpses of an old
man intercut with jake and his
girlfriend driving while we hear the
girlfriend's internal monologue
we see the old man starting his day in
the morning looking out the window in an
old swing set and working as a janitor
in a high school
often these cuts occur right after jake
speaks which heavily implies that the
janitor and jake are somehow connected
throughout i'm thinking of ending things
we're confronted with yet more symbols
that not only is jake connected with the
janitor but the girlfriend is too
for example she recites one of her poems
on the car ride to dinner
coming home is terrible whether the dogs
lick your face or not and she later
reads the exact same poem she thought
she'd composed out of a book of poetry
by author eva hd in jake's childhood
bedroom
coming home is terrible whether the dogs
lick your face or not
during the drive the girlfriend glimpses
the same swing set the old man spied out
his window
only now it's standing in front of a
dilapidated house the basic events of
the story blur and change from scene to
scene like the age of jake's parents the
outfits everyone wears and the story of
how she and jake first met
even more telling jake adamantly works
to keep her out of the house's basement
he's hiding in there
hmm what
when she finally goes in she discovers
the washing machine is full of identical
janitor uniforms
like the broken mirror telling us that
the girlfriend's identity and self-image
is broken in some significant way
the house's basement is a frequent
symbol for a character's subconscious
and the fact that these uniforms seem to
lurk in jake's basement seems pretty
significant
eventually enough of these kind of clues
stack up to indicate that the girlfriend
isn't really there at all
none of the events of the film's main
story are happening in what you'd call
reality
they're all happening in the mind of
that old man the janitor
the revelation that the movie is
unfolding inside the janitor's mind
becomes more explicit by the end
early in the film while driving to his
parents house jake describes watching
the kids practice and perform the
musical oklahoma
though he doesn't specify which kids
he's talking about and immediately after
that we cut again to the janitor
watching high school students rehearsing
the show later on when the girlfriend
has followed jake into the supposedly
abandoned high school she runs into the
janitor
after they chat we see a rendition of
the dream ballet sequence from oklahoma
but the actors are instead dressed as
jake the girlfriend and the janitor
when the ballet ends jake and his
girlfriend are gone and the janitor's
left all alone
he changes out of his uniform and back
into his clothes trudges to his pickup
truck in the snowy school parking lot
and promptly starts freaking out
all the while scenes related to the
events of jake and his girlfriend's
story play out seemingly in his mind
he strips naked then follows the ghost
of a dead maggot ridden pig back into
the school
that's a clear reference to a moment
earlier in the film when jake tells his
girlfriend about how his father had to
kill maggot ridden pigs on the farm many
years earlier
and after the janitor follows the ghost
pig that's the last we see of him the
film hard cuts to jake wearing high
school theater production level old man
makeup
accepting a nobel prize and then singing
the song lonely room from oklahoma
so what does that all mean time for some
context
the antagonist in oklahoma is a guy
named judd a creep who lives alone at a
dirty smokehouse and who's infatuated
with the musical's heroine lori
his rival for lori's affections is curly
a handsome cowboy
to make a long musical short no one
really likes judd and curly and lori toy
with him during the course of their own
courtship
along the way curly literally tells judy
should kill himself because no one likes
him and that's the only way anyone will
finally realize how much they should
have appreciated him
oh you never know how many people like
you till he did
needless to say it's no fun to be judd
and that's basically jake in this film
to quote oklahoma judd is a dud and to
that end so is jake the janitor
in the musical lonely room is judd's bow
to make lori his wife and finally get
out of his dingy smokehouse
to go from dud to stud it's a song of
hope and longing from a character who's
detested by everyone around him
and by the end of the musical spoiler
judd dies falling on his own knife after
he tries and fails to attack curly on
the day of his wedding delorey
the questions the film asks are
troubling to ponder how does it feel to
be unloved and unlovable
what's it like to be judd one of the
lies we tell ourselves to keep from the
brutal realization that we might be the
dud of someone else's story
ultimately the film's theme is pretty
succinctly summed up during the
disturbing scene where the janitor
follows the ghost pig through the
school's halls presumably on his way to
end things
the pig tells him it's not bad once you
stop feeling sorry for yourself because
you're just a pig
or even worse a pig infested with
maggots someone has to be a pig infested
with maggots right
it might as well be you it's the luck of
the draw this is a movie about a hero
who's
actually a pig infested with maggots
this person is alone and has always been
alone
the janitor has never had love and he's
always imagined it from afar
hoping against hope that he might
someday find a lorry or lucy or luisa
of his own even if he has no real idea
as to how that might happen
his life isn't like a romantic comedy
like the fictional rom-com called order
up that he watches during his break
about one-third through the film
i'm thinking of ending things explores
what life is like from the perspective
of a non-heroic protagonist
we're all the heroes of our own stories
but what if our stories don't go
anywhere
what if instead of living happily ever
after with your soul mate you simply get
old in your crappy job
and then well you start thinking of
ending things
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one